ladies an gentlemen opposition premiered
last night and I'm in our 25 of
reviewing our reviews so again these are
real-life press clippings we start at
the so-called Daily Beast which
misquoted us we said Alex Jones is a
Raging Bull virile masculine Pharaoh but
they said
Jones is a raging bowl bo WL and you
might think it's just a typo but the
Beast hyperlinked to a picture of a bowl
and as such as any bull ladies and
gentlemen it's a salad bowl so obviously
The Daily Beast is in the pocket of big
ko and since we first discovered this
error
I mean message The Daily Beast is
subsequently taken down the bowl
language and erased the hyperlink
coincidence I think not I mean that next
we go over to the AV Club more of an AV
cult connected directly to skull and
bones and Freemasons and the beyhive
when they say quote Nicole Thurmond
scene whooping it up is a lone black
person at a trump rally where she's
habitually posed by Trump staffers right
behind the podium every time is an
analogous is an analogue those
conspicuously few non white faces Trump
a bitch who will he trots out to refute
charges of bigotry ladies and gentlemen
that was one sentence one long sentence
that used the word habitually twice
almost as if this writer has some kind
of I don't know routine using that word
whatever it means these are the lies the
mainstream media is trying to tell you
and every single one of them has since
been taken down redacted hidden from
your view but we at Oppo radio know how
to take screenshots
we're screen shooting for you next we
move over to this review from the
Chicago Tribune which refers to a
fictional MSNBC host Christ Hays now my
colleague Laura gray says that this is a
typo but ladies and gentlemen you and I
know
there's no such thing as a type of
Freud's theory was that if you put it
down on paper you meant it so this is a
class example of the mainstream media
trying to slip its cultish iconography
into our reviews so be on the lookout
ladies and gentlemen for other examples
of deities paired with MSNBC hosts it
starts with Christ Hays but look out for
Buda Maddow
or Vishnu Matthews when you see those
symbols in your Tribune's and your
heralds and your times is that's how you
know that the mainstream media is trying
to brainwash you with their religious
symbols oh I see how it could have been
Chris